[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL SMURL: Technology is
upending our entire industry
and has quickened in the
last few years-- shifting
the traditional media and
print-based organization to one
that is a global digital media
organization. "The New York
Times" is known for
the highest quality
journalism on the planet.
We've been in business
for over 160 years.
Folks who are using our
apps are more deeply
engaging with the content there.
They're more likely to come
back frequently, go deeper,
and ultimately
become subscribers.
KATE HARRIS: We actually
debuted our Android app in 2010.
So we were very early
to the platform.
And since then, it's
just been about growth.
And it's been-- over the
past two years-- explosive.
To build a successful
Android product,
it's essential to have a
team that really understands
the platform, that lives
the platform, that's
Android-obsessed.
And we are very lucky to have
that at "The New York Times."
Android makes it
really easy to build
apps that are intuitive to use.
It's also easy as an app
developer or publisher
to build apps that use our
own typography, to make
the app feel like
"The New York Times."
Before we integrated
Play Billing,
our subscription process
took around two minutes.
And we were asking
our users to fill out
a series of forms,
all on their phone.
And now with Play Billing,
because the user has a credit
card or their Paypal information
associated with their account,
the user can subscribe
to "The New York Times"
within two taps.
Some of the tap features I
really like about Play Billing
was, one, we're able to
enable local currency
billing in over 50 countries.
And, two, it was very
easy to add a free trial.
With Play Billing,
we're able to realize
a 125% increase in
subscription conversion.
PAUL SMURL: We did the math.
We looked at whether
the upside, in terms
of incremental subscriptions,
would more than
offset the 30% that
we pay to Google.
And in fact, it does.
Android is an incredibly
important platform for us.
It's one of our fastest
growing platforms.
We consider our investment
in Android an essential one.
And in terms of our
international growth ambitions,
Android for us has been a
table stakes investment.
[MUSIC PLAYING]